today we're talking about a playstation
update an elden ring update and a call
of duty update
the latest firmware has gone live for
playstation 4 and playstation 5 consoles
adding several new features and tweaking
the user interface ps4 users can expect
a retuned party experience like the
ability to create or join open and
closed parties ps5 users will also
receive this update while users with
accounts registered in the us and uk can
try out a preview of a new voice command
system in the user interface department
enhancements to game base and trophy
cards as well as accessibility features
like mono audio for headphones have been
added the playstation app and
playstation remote play app have also
been upgraded and it will now be easier
to access the friends parties and
messaging features on playstation 5. in
a blog post sony also teased that
variable refresh rate support will be
coming to playstation 5 soon which aims
to make gameplay smoother on hdmi 2.1
compatible tvs and pc monitors and if
you're looking for more info on hdmi 2.1
i'll have a gamespot article on the
subject linked down below sony hasn't
provided an exact date for the launch of
variable refresh rate but it did mention
it will launch in quote the months ahead
so eventually and unfortunately for some
people right after the release of this
update the playstation network went down
however at the time of this recording
service looks to have been restored
during the downtime players reported
problems related to launching games apps
and network features additionally the
playstation store was also affected with
reports of problems related to
purchasing downloading searching you
know the whole bit in other update news
from software has released a new update
for elden ring in the form of patch
103.2
which mainly focuses on bug fixes the
frustrating bug that caused players to
die when descending bestial sanctum has
been addressed along with a multiplayer
issue where fans would be teleported to
different areas of the map the latter
involved many enemy players invading and
deliberately crashing players games
making it a serious problem and sticking
with the update talk let's briefly go
over call of duty's mid-season update
with season 2's war zone update major
changes have been made to rebirth island
which previously had seen very few
changes since the initial launch in
december 2020. the new reinforced look
for rebirth island introduces a new
point of interest and completely
overhauls some popular map locations to
celebrate these changes raven software's
rebirth reinforced event will award
players for dropping into the new
version of the map rebirth reinforced
will last for three full weeks running
from march 23rd to april 14th in the
vanguard multiplayer side of things
players can look forward to a new 12v12
mode called arms race the mode is set on
a new large scale map and calls on
players to capture and hold bases
vanguard also introduces new vehicles
including the motorcycle the cd-12
transport four-seater and the powerful
tank and since this is an update themed
video go ahead and hit the comment
section and give me an update on your
life
how you doing
everything okay over there
all right just want to check in let me
know